>> Will Sentance: Tôi nghĩ đây là phạm vi của khoảnh khắc tốt đẹp để xem
cách ngày càng tiêu chuẩn hơn để làm điều này ngày nay.
Điều đó sử dụng tính năng này của một cách xác định hoặc khai báo mới hoặc
lưu các hàm trong JavaScript mà chúng ta đã thấy ngày hôm qua.
Đó là kiểu hàm mũi tên của chúng tôi.
Theo kiểu hàm mũi tên của chúng tôi, khai báo hoặc
chức năng lưu, >> Will Sentance: Tự động,
Tôi sẽ nói với bạn ngay bây giờ, là phạm vi từ vựng.
Điều đó có nghĩa là nơi chúng tôi lưu hàm hoặc, hãy để tôi làm rõ điều đó, không, xin lỗi.
Có phải, đó là nhiệm vụ này có phạm vi từ vựng.
Có nghĩa là, khi chúng ta lưu hàm, khi chúng ta thực thi nó,
điều này được đặt thành được xác định bởi nơi hàm được lưu.
Vì vậy, nếu nó được lưu ở nơi đây là người dùng 1, khi chúng tôi chạy nó,
bên trong sẽ là giá trị này từ nơi hàm được lưu, đó là User1.
Vì vậy, hãy chỉ xem ví dụ đó ở đây.
Bây giờ chúng ta đã xác định bằng một hàm mũi tên, hãy thực hiện thay đổi nhỏ này.
Hãy nhanh chóng cùng nhau thực hiện, một lần nữa, hãy đảm bảo rằng chúng ta đã nắm được.
Hãy nhanh chóng thực thi nó một lần nữa, vì vậy chúng tôi đang thực hiện ở đây.
Đây là những điều phức tạp nhỏ ở đây, nhưng
phần thưởng nhỏ thú vị mà tôi muốn bao gồm cho tất cả các bạn.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi đang chạy user1.increment.
Nó chạy phương thức gia tăng từ cửa hàng hàm thông qua user1.
Tôi đã nói bạn vượt qua điều đó nhanh chóng.
Dan, user1.increment, user1 tham gia?
>> Diễn giả 2: Bộ nhớ toàn cầu.
>> Will Sentance: Bộ nhớ chung, chúng ta đang tìm phương thức gia tăng, nó có ở đó không?
>> Người nói 2: Không, vì vậy chúng tôi chuyển sang phần proto, và
hãy để tôi tìm nó trong hàm người dùng nên lưu trữ đối tượng.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, chúng tôi lấy mã của nó, và chúng tôi nghĩ sẽ thực thi nó.
Và điều đầu tiên và bộ nhớ cục bộ Dan là?
>> Loa 2: Không đổi ở 1, cái này.
>> Will Sentance: Vâng, như một tham số, không có vấn đề, đó là?
>> Người nói 2: Người dùng1. >> Will Sentance: Đó là gì
chúng tôi hy vọng vì đó là những gì chúng tôi đang chạy chức năng này
sở hữu mà chúng tôi hy vọng nó sẽ ảnh hưởng đến điều này.
Chúng tôi luôn muốn có chức năng và dữ liệu của mình.
Có thể sử dụng chức năng trực tiếp trên dữ liệu ngay tại đó và
thì đó là loại toàn bộ mục tiêu của việc này.
Vì vậy, đừng quên điều đó khi chúng ta đi sâu vào những phức tạp này và
đừng quên mục tiêu tổng thể đó.
Đây là những gì một trông tuyệt vời.
Hãy khai báo chức năng đó Dan.
>> Diễn giả 2: Tại 1 và.
>> Will Sentance: Trong chức năng mũi tên ngôi sao, nhưng nó không khác nhau.
Đây rồi.
Và chúng ta ngay lập tức làm gì với nó, Dan?
>> Người nói 2: Chúng tôi gọi nó, e thực hiện nó.
>> Will Sentance: Chúng tôi gọi nó, e thực hiện nó.
Cái gì mới toanh vậy Dan?
>> Diễn giả 2: Thực thi loạia.
>> Will Sentance: Việc thực thi đẹp và trong bộ nhớ cục bộ.
Bởi vì nó là một chức năng mũi tên.
Tôi không biết, tôi mặc dù chúng tôi cần nó, nhưng nó nằm trong chức năng của chúng tôi.
Đây là nhiệm vụ bên trong bộ nhớ cục bộ, nó sẽ là toàn cục vì lưu ý,
một quy tắc đơn giản của chúng tôi là bất kỳ chức năng nào đang được chạy ở phía bên phải
của dấu chấm bất kể phía bên trái sẽ là nhiệm vụ danh sách.
Nhưng khi không có dấu chấm ở đây, nó sẽ mặc định là chung cho cửa sổ.
Trừ khi hàm đó được định nghĩa là hàm mũi tên,
trong trường hợp này Dan của chúng ta nhiệm vụ này sẽ là gì?
>> Loa 2: Vẫn còn User1.
>> Will Sentance: Người dùng một, chính xác nhiệm vụ này là gì xung quanh định nghĩa
trong đó 1 là phạm vi từ điển.
Nó tĩnh là phạm vi, sự phân công này.
Đây là một nhiệm vụ tĩnh hoặc từ điển, nghĩa là nó từ
thời điểm xác định mà chúng tôi đặt cái này thành Người dùng1.
Do đó, dòng mã this.score cộng với cộng,
sẽ đánh giá những gì Todd, bây giờ?
>> Người thuyết trình 2: User1.score ++.
>> Will Sentance: Tuyệt vời, user1.score ++.
Bạn phải vượt qua một vài cấp độ.
1, 2, 3, có thuộc tính điểm của chúng tôi.
Nó sẽ tăng lên bốn nhưng, hãy tăng nó lên,
>> Will Sentance: 5, những người tuyệt vời.
Đây là một cách tốt để giải quyết vấn đề này cho
viết mã sạch này ở đây.
Tất cả những người phù hợp, chúng ta hãy bắt đầu bằng ngón tay cái ở đây vào thời điểm này
trên bất kỳ phần thưởng nào mà bất kỳ ai muốn thêm bất kỳ ngón tay cái nào, vâng, hãy tiếp tục đi Peter.
>> Người thuyết trình 2: Sẽ tuyên bố số gia tăng
tài sản như một chức năng mũi tên cũng giúp chúng tôi?
>> Will Sentance: Sẽ không?
Bởi vì nếu chúng tôi đã làm như vậy, khi chúng tôi chạy số gia đó.
Vì vậy, câu hỏi của Peter là điều gì xảy ra nếu chúng ta nói một gia số như một hàm mũi tên?
Nếu chúng tôi chạy nó, thì nhiệm vụ này có được xác định bởi nơi nó đang được chạy không
ở phía bên tay phải của dấu chấm hoặc nơi nó được lưu trữ, trên toàn cầu?
Bởi nơi nó được cất giữ, và do đó toàn bộ sẽ tan rã.
Và bây giờ đây sẽ không phải là User1.
Vì vậy, chúng tôi không muốn sử dụng các hàm mũi tên cho bao gồm
phương pháp của chúng tôi trên các đối tượng.
Nhưng đối với các chức năng bên trong chúng mà chúng tôi muốn chỉ ra ở đó
phương pháp mà chúng đã được xác định, hoàn hảo.